excitement for the golden knights it
continues with many flocking to get to
the stores to buy all the night's gear
we said eight news now reporter Brian
will to the official team store the
Arsenal at City National Arena to find
out how people Brian are gearing up for
the big game
the knights are headed to the Stanley
Cup and fans are headed here to get swag
before the first game on Saturday
we got the course big shirts
could not have the opportunity to get
the purple jersey a steady flow of fans
were at the Arsenal following Monday
night's blowout game the line extended
all the way around the store it included
Mike Villa Jr and his son Caden we've
got hats we've got shirts
we've got jackets and they have big
plans for the first game of the series
we're looking at uh possibly going to
the game we're looking at that it's a
special moment where I was born and
raised here so it was heat and uh you
know these moments don't come by too
often there was even excitement outside
the store
inspiring the next generation of fans
pretty excited
[Music]
now t-shirts are the most popular item
fans are buying the Arsenal and City
National Arena it is open from 10 a.m to
8 P.M expect a crowd